good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy hump day
you made it to the middle of the week
congratulations celebrate by humping
someone you love jackie get over here
might i suggest bryce and nicest that's
always a good suggestion i'm never going
to turn down an opportunity to hump rice
or dice no no no no no
happy hump day can't believe it's only
wednesday yet here we are it's better
you know what it is it's better than
tuesday and it's definitely better than
monday 100
now
starting now we'll be cruising down
through the end of the week it's like
downhill you know yeah the week is a
hill it's an incline and monday tuesday
wednesday is the journey up
wednesday on down yeah and you know
what's cool about wednesdays even though
obviously it's not ideal it's not the
best day of the week
you're allowed to start having hope and
that can really fuel you through a long
workday yeah and everybody hates
wednesdays you know so it's not like
we're complaining do people hate
wednesdays
yeah because it's like the hump day
i don't hate wednesdays at all like i'm
like oh my god okay now it's like we can
start looking forward to the weekend
like on monday and tuesday the weekend
is so far out of my mind tuesday is
really
a nice day a nice day i think tuesday
tuesday never hurt anybody i disagree
monday of course is extremely nefarious
problematic monday needs to be canceled
and i know a lot of people give flack on
monday but i think a lot of that energy
should be reserved for tuesday tuesday
is arguably worse we've already been
through a whole monday and you feel like
you deserve for it to be like thursday
but then it's just tuesday no but
tuesday you've been eased into the week
it's not as stark as the monday you know
whatever you had waiting for you on
monday you accomplished in tuesday you
can you can look anew and on tuesday
you're ready for the week no no i
totally did then on wednesday you're
like it's still the week no on wednesday
i'm like there is a glimmer of hope like
i can see this tiniest bit of light out
of this tunnel on tuesday i'm still very
much in the tunnel you know what i mean
okay fine and then thursday's just
gorgeous
friday is spectacular you know what i'm
gonna have another hot take like you
can't be negative all negative all the
time [ __ ] i wasn't you let me let me
see what i was gonna say i think
thursdays are incredible the truckers
for thursday are here
i think thursdays are incredible and
like i kind of feel like sometimes
friday's like a little bit of a letdown
like it's kind of anticlimactic no it's
like
i like thursday because we're so close
to the weekend we have it to look
forward to and then friday it's it's
almost like it's already here and you
need to start
appreciating like i don't like when
something is here i like when it's a
builder yeah i mean i have like a an
adoration for fridays obviously because
i'm human but also because like growing
up on fridays in school we would always
get out super early because it was
shabbat and we're going to jewish to get
out of school at 5 00 p.m yeah on
regular days we got out at like three no
in like the nice time of the year like
12 30 1 30 when it would get dark really
early so some of my fondest memories are
like just being done with the week and
having like a nice window to nap before
shabbat dinner and like just the weekend
could come and that's like for so long
been my attachment to
fridays but i don't really have that
experience with fridays anymore no
so i kind of am loving thursdays okay do
your thing thursdays are the new friday
especially if you are your own business
woman and you can cancel work on friday
and it's summer fridays and we also
can't ever like we never cancel a show
that wasn't planned to be cancelled
unless we have the no no virus oh don't
we talk such a big game like yeah we
work when we want to when we don't when
we don't we are a slave to the schedule
we're yeah we're we're we try and keep
it really tight and like i know it seems
like maybe we take off a lot of time but
we try it always has to be like planned
in advance ask for pto
like unless you it's the nono virus
that's really the only time we ever
abruptly canceled a show and honestly i
really um don't want to go down that
road talking about the nono virus
because over the weekend no no no over
the weekend me and ben were with you and
a couple of your friends and we were
telling them about the nano virus
because ben had caught the nono virus at
your friend rebecca's birthday party um
and so we gave him like the whole
rundown and honestly i feel fatigued and
traumatized from that conversation and i
can't talk about it no i don't i have no
desire
you're free from desire
free from desire so it's wednesday which
means we're going to be hilarious
obviously um it also means we have dear
toasters our advice segment so that'll
be at the end of the show and we've got
a couple stories to
to tell you about some legal news
some
more disney news claudia picked four out
of the five and you guys can guess which
ones are which yeah yeah yeah that'll be
fun totally
also um since it's wednesday i'm being
reminded of two things one last week
when we were doing deer toasters i don't
know if i was just like forklamped or
overwhelmed but we had three submissions
and i only read two of them that's
really funny i have no idea why and then
yesterday's episode you called me and
you were like wait did you realize that
when we were talking about the saint and
pete davidson story we went off on a
tangent and literally never recapped the
story never even discussed what they did
who they were what you need to know we
just saw the word cheesecake factory and
we went down the rabbit hole and we
never came back to it because i was like
you know writing a little caption like
we talked about boom boom and then so i
went to look at the stories and i was
like what did we say about pete and
saint nothing no we talked about my
internship
it's a california pizza kitchen yeah and
cheesecake factory yeah
we are nothing if not professional you
just never know where the show's gonna
take you and like okay pete and satan
went to walmart now you know no and you
really can't throw cheesecake factory
into a story without expecting people to
you know go off on tangents harp and
larp harp and larp 100
that's what we did we're the harpers and
the larpers we are harping larp and
harbin larp and harper
um so what's with you
i started a new book last night well i
finished my book on the plaza i told you
guys yesterday but then there were a
bunch of pictures in the back so i had
to tap through to actually get the you
know
for having read it i rated it a 3.5 you
know i don't think it could have ever
been any better than that but now i have
all this useless information about the
plaza so if you want to know anything
about the plaza come and ask me and i've
probably already forgotten
then i started this book called the lost
summers of newport
it's by three authors a trifecta
uh one of them is beatriz williams who
is a historical fiction writer who i've
never read but she's like a christian
hannah and i don't know why i've never
read one of her books so i'm excited and
it's about like gilded age summers in
newport very much like the show
so i've heard good things and that's
just my scene that's my scene you're
such a newport 1899 newport is that's
where i'm at
looking for me it's 1889 and i'm in
newport right and now i want to go back
to newport and i know like a historical
tour well no i'll go with you um you
would like it and now that you've
watched gilded age you don't think no
for sure but like when we went to
newport last time we did like wineries
bars like that's very much i think like
the energy i will be you know bringing
if we do go to newport of course but we
could do one day where we look at the
houses like you did in second grade i
have been to the house
in second grade but like she couldn't
have cared um also we do need to go back
to newport because the last time we went
to newport was the situation with the
extremely hasty flush yes and we have to
eradicate that memory from our brains
entirely yeah and if you don't know
we're talking about because you're new
from tick tock go look at our episode
the extremely hasty flush it happens in
the beginning and it's a really
traumatizing moment and it's a teachable
moment for everyone who's ever gonna use
a rest stop in connecticut because they
do all these high-tech bus stops they're
really gorgeous and congratulations to
everyone in connecticut but they got
really aggressive with their flushers
also it's a podcast only episode so
don't go looking for it on youtube good
advice um yeah i feel like you know
every i feel i feel like you know a lot
of um
creators and youtube personalities and
influencers are
tied to a cause you know they they are a
cause-driven platform
and i really feel like we should be
championing the cause of no automatic
toilets at rest stops
no you don't know what you're gonna find
when that's a can of worms you don't
want to open no i think i'm going to
open it no you don't want toilet bowls
that are full no what's so in that's
true that's that's very true but what's
so annoying is that like automatic flush
means like it's a renovated
bathroom and it's like why can we have
renovated bathrooms just with regular
flushes you know it's like i don't want
to give up the new clean renovated
bathroom yeah you know
yeah
i guess they could just be like a little
less hasty is what i would say there
should be like a 10 second timer just in
case you drop your keys totally
traumatized it's a rental jaguar this
stop like i listen to the jaguar that
you rented you splurged and you were
like what could go wrong find you two
girls who will walk into a rental car
a budget rental car and be like give us
the nicest car you have and they
actually had a jaguar that was and it
was so fun to drive it like i hate that
i can't even reminisce on that weekend
like we had so much fun oh i they're two
separate events for me you weren't
driving because when i was reading the
book i forgot about the flush you
weren't driving you weren't the one who
dropped the keys and you weren't also
the one who secretly like thought she
had coveted i woke up that morning like
with such a painful snap like feeling in
my throat and we were driving everyone
back so i'm like i'm gonna drive so fast
get everyone i don't wanna i had the
window open i was like i totally have
coved um
we all had colds when we got home from
that member i didn't have covid but like
and you know when you like during that
time every time you woke up like hung
over you're like oh my god i have
covered yeah but even if you had it then
we were all in such close quarters the
whole time like we were on the same team
no i just like had anxiety and i'm like
i don't want anyone to know that like
i'm not feeling well so let me just book
it we were making incredible time it is
like a five hour drive and i was going
90 miles an hour we were gonna make it
back in two and a half hours like dead
ass we stopped for one [ __ ]
second and literally the whole day was
derailed this grandma we had to wait in
the parking lot wait for a local taxi
wait for the triple a it was horrible
yeah
i'm glad we relive that yeah but there
are two separate things to me and also
just be glad that it was claudia who
dropped the keys because if it was
anybody else
claudia would have murdered them okay so
the murder that was murder on
the freeway that was the general
consensus of the group like we're
annoyed at you but thank god it was you
because like you would be so much more
annoyed at us and while i can definitely
see how someone would think that of me i
would never forgive whoever it was i
really actually don't agree you know
i think i would be relieved that it
wasn't me
and i think like i mean i had nowhere to
go if i was like in a rush like to make
an appointment or something i think i
would have been just as helpful in
calling the taxi and everything i'm a
doer you know i do
um i don't think i would have been as
scary as everyone thought i was gonna be
and it actually kind of hurt my feelings
that everyone thought i was gonna be so
like scary good i'm glad that it
resonated with you because that's how
scary you would have been but i wouldn't
have i'm telling you no claudia no i
like i'm telling you i i probably would
have thought it was funny
if it was on someone else's like for me
the rental car was under my name right
my license my credit card and it was a
[ __ ] jaguar that we had to leave in
the middle of connecticut so like if it
was on someone else's ass i don't think
i would have been so stressed you know
okay i really believe that just know
that he's health and just i know i am
knowing myself that she also probably
would have not waited with the team and
called an uber and left oh no that's
really what you think of me i never
would do that i'm a girl's girl okay the
only thing that was like thank god there
were so many thank gods one that it was
claudia and no one else two the car was
over the car was open imagine if all of
our stuff was locked in there we would
have had to wait with the car wait for
it to get open
but thankfully we were able to get our
stuff and like leave the car and budget
came and picked it up honestly shout out
to budget
yeah i was waiting like months later to
get a charge a hundred thousand dollars
for the jaguars
like go to buy a house and your credit
score is in the tubes and you're like
what happened they're like you never
return the job
that's true but i do check my credit
quite often so i think i would know oh
my god
i did get like a big charge from them
like for the triple a it's like twenty
five hundred dollars yeah that seems
fair but that's not the price of a
jaguar sounds like the end of the
redheads that seems fair every time we
write the book that's funny we do the
average of all of our ratings so it's
fair yeah and snitch every single time
because that seems fair that seems fair
you know what math is fair that's the
thing about math it's a magic number
okay instead of going down this
triggering yeah
right re-trip down memory lane let's get
into the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp life can be overwhelming and
many people are burned out without even
knowing it symptoms can include lack of
motivation feeling helpless or trapped
detachment fatigue and more and we
associate burnout with work but that's
not the only cause any of the roles in
our life can lead us to feel burned out
and better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing you stress in your
life
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours
your mental health is not something to
put on the back burner girls and boys
take care of it today with better help
and morning toast listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
toast that's betterhelp betterhelp.com
toast
thank you our first story a little legal
news todd and julie chrisley have been
found guilty of being fraud and tax
evasion
reality stars todd and julie chrisley
were found guilty of bank fraud and tax
evasion team tmz reported on tuesday
according to a court clerk for the
northern district of georgia the
couple's accountant peter
tatino was also found guilty on a series
of related charges including aiding and
abetting the filing of false tax returns
a sentencing date has yet to be
scheduled and the stars are currently
free on bond todd's attorney told tmz
they plan to appeal the jury's decision
saying we are disappointed in the
verdict they were initially indicted in
august 2019 and a new indictment was
filed in february of this year
prosecutors allege that the duo
submitted fake documents to banks when
applying for loans and that julie also
submitted false credit reports and bank
statements when trying to rent a house
in california i mean i love when they're
like we're gonna appeal at the verdict
isn't sure like this isn't like a murder
he said she said did she didn't she like
there's literally a paper trail
whether you paid your taxes or not did
you evade them so
i just feel like that's like such a lame
response like
you don't just get found guilty on tax
evasion no one's ever been framed for
tax evasion like you either paid your
taxes or you did it so that is the first
thought i have and the second thought i
have is like obviously i'm not surprised
by this i think like if you've been at
all familiar with the chrisleys over the
years it's very unclear what they do for
a living really yeah like and especially
in the early season say this big house
and todd was like this big like real
estate is like what people say they do
when they don't have a job right of
course they're very so ambiguous you
could be
at any different like level of real
estate right you could be uh agent
renting apartments you could be the
biggest developer in new york city and
mogul right so it's just like this big
it kind of gives the vibe like when
someone says like i'm an entrepreneur
like what does that mean yeah yeah no it
leaves a lot open for interpretation it
requires follow-up questions
yeah
so in the first couple seasons like they
came on the show and like i remember
todd was like i've made my money i want
to make the next big uh
department store in atlanta and
obviously never came to fruition but
they were always like living this
extravagant life and it wasn't clear
what they did for a living julie was
like a stay-at-home mom and todd was
like kind of like retired it was really
bizarre i've never really watched an
entire episode of the show so if you had
asked me to like tell you who they are
and what they do like i kind of thought
he was a preacher
honestly i totally see him he gives like
preacher vibes because i feel like he's
always like preaching to his family yeah
no and i think he's definitely a man of
the lord and it's like chrisley knows
best what does he know what god knows
because he's a preacher
that's
literally the best call you've ever made
um but no he's not a preacher but he
does preach quite a bit um so it's
always felt like they were living beyond
their means um in a confusing way and
then there was like a period where they
downsized
um which is never good on reality tv
like it they're always like well the
kids are in college like no it's always
a little like what's going on so they
moved to like this smaller house it was
still really nice but like much smaller
and they've always just been confusing
about their finances so this does not
surprise me in the least yeah it'll be
interesting to see what kind of
sentencing they get and also the verdict
comes just weeks after todd's
ex-business partner mark braddock
claimed that the reality star cheated on
julie with him and that they paid off a
blackmailer to keep the alleged gay
affair a secret so there's a lot
it's layered it's layered like most
things okay i mean
is not cancelled that's so crazy aside
from that gay affair thing
it is really sad to see like another
reality star fall into like this trope
of tax evasion like it's becoming like
standard for like people who become
famous kind of overnight make money it's
like it's giving mike sorrentino yeah
well there's two things one i think a
lot of reality stars or people who
become famous really quickly don't know
how or that they have to pay the amount
of taxes that they do and that's like
mike's situation i mean i don't know i
think mike's was nefarious oh really i
think it was like more intentional than
that but i think that happens a lot i
don't think you necessarily go to jail
for that but then there's also like
intentional fraud which is like teresa
this is jojo
yeah yeah well
as much as it pains me because you know
i hate the irs like
you can't [ __ ] with them like no you've
got to pay your taxes you've got to pay
your taxes i've thought about not doing
it many times like one of these days
like i'm just going to stop but today
and then we'll be reading about you i
know but like finally people will be
talking about me is it worth it if they
let me go to like one of those nice
prisons no no sorry no no not for you
no
so um wishing them you know
best of luck in your sentencing i feel
like
this isn't the type of case where you
get like a plea deal because there's
like nothing to
no one to rat out yeah maybe like
restitution could help yeah but i don't
know like how much money they've got i
don't know either
we shall see best of luck we shall see
best of luck next story little casting
news the role that a million girls will
kill for
is going to julia garner she has been
offered the madonna role in the
universal biopic of the star inventing
anna actress julia garner has been
offered the role of madonna in a
forthcoming biopic about the pop icon
source is familiar with the project told
variety she has emerged the favorite
from over a dozen candidates one insider
added and has for months been speculated
as a front-runner for the part a
performance madonna will shepherd
herself as director garner's team is
considering and expected to accept the
offer said another source so the offer
is out it is not confirmed sign sealed
and delivered i mean this is just
reminding me of like years ago when we
were talking about the casting for elvis
right it's the role a million girls
wanted um and they kind of went with
like the not super obvious choice with
austin butler and with julia garner now
people are obviously like using her hair
as
like the thing in like all the pictures
because yeah in the pictures they do a
side-by-side it's pretty it's pretty
good yeah like her curly blonde natural
hair like is really similar to the look
madonna had when she became like
an icon
so i see it visually
um i'm not like a huge madonna girl and
i'm not a huge julia garner girl so i
have to say i probably won't see this
movie yeah i agree
also some of the other names that had
been floated yeah were florence pew i
don't see it euphoria star alexa demi
oh
the only thing is they don't really look
alike well you can make anyone look like
anyone odessa young bibi rexa and skye
ferreira but i remember reading on
dumois once that liz gillies was up for
the role and now i can't get past that
because she would be amazing because
she's an amazing actress and amazing
singer and like do these girly sing i
don't know
that's such a good call and it's kind of
ruining this movie for me because now
i'm just like what should have been yeah
should have been liz yeah i was also
thinking um
and i don't know what a like age they're
looking for but um what's her name lily
james she was so good in pam and tommy
like irrecognizable like i just see her
as like this downton abbey cinderella
like princess royal vibe but in pam and
tommy she was like so transformative she
like wasn't even herself so i really
could see her doing this well yeah but i
mean it's julia gardner yeah we should
stop
like larping as it being anyone else but
would it be an episode of the morning
toast if we weren't live-action
role-playing no and
i agree this doesn't like do that much
for me but i'm sure it'll be good she's
a really good actress yeah she's very
she was good as anna delvey yeah she was
very good as anna delvey because like i
literally hated her yeah you know i
still haven't seen it and i'm like going
to see it like the fanfare
yeah no i i successfully because i had
just given birth so i successfully was
able to escape but like if you are ever
looking for something like it was good
and it was like really interesting
because i feel like even though we all
became like invested in the storm we all
read the vanity fair article at the time
like the like the ins and outs of like
how she actually did it like how do you
almost convince the biggest bank in the
world like literally a fortress i think
it was called fortress to give you money
like the way in which she did it was
actually kind of interesting to find out
like exactly how can learn some tips
yeah if you're a fraudster in the making
con woman want to be like definitely
check it out yeah but i would also
imagine like one i'm sure this
sort of series inspires plenty of con
men and women but it also alerts other
people like this is what people do also
my only problem with inventing anna is
like they took it way too far like when
it was over like the article came out
anna was wearing yada yada it should
have been over but like the journalists
like just had to go to germany and meet
her family like stop it it was like
classic like annoying journalist you
know yeah classic classic
are you ready for our next story
um
i think that i am
and just like that season two storyline
will include samantha's character
the sex and the city spin-off series and
just like that will welcome back the
show's beloved samantha jones albeit
virtually the hbo max series which was
renewed for season two star sarah
jessica parker cynthia nixon and kristen
davis and a much buzzed about absence
from the original series star kim
catrell but fret notch showrunner
michael patrick king revealed to variety
the show's storyline will feature the
dearly missed pr guru king who
previously said the door wasn't open for
her return was asked if fans can expect
to see samantha's character creep into
the storyline of the upcoming season
a bold and clear-cut yes was his answer
he remained tight-lipped about his plans
for the show telling the outlet it's
also new right now one of my big roles
is don't tell things until they are real
okay completely aside when you got my
lunch order yesterday at my house what
the [ __ ] was there a soup
i'm just remembering that i ordered a
soup
and i never got it okay um
first of all what
something about this story made me think
of soup okay so second of all um zach
was the one who opened the bag and
passed me your wrap so i could put on a
plate for you got it so you would have
to ask that because i didn't even get i
didn't even open the bag and get my
lunch i like wasn't okay got it maybe
it's in the fridge but i just remember
like i was looking forward to that soup
and then
i don't know where it went okay thanks
um i don't know i have no information
for you i'm joking um
and back to the story
i feel like
this is a big nothing burger okay
because he said will her character be
like some part of the plot yes her
character was part of the plot in the
first season carrie was texting with
samantha while she was in paris yeah
like when they said virtually again like
maybe carrie's on a zoom with samantha
but we don't see samantha and maybe
they'd get like some kim control
impersonator to have a voiceover right
anything to cut out the only person
who's worth watching on the show 100
the only other way i can see them doing
this is them recasting samantha which i
think would be like literally the worst
idea of all time because samantha was a
great character for sure but she was
really made exceptional by kim catrell
it's not just a role that anyone could
play totally it's like moira you know no
that would be insane that would be so
stupid i hope they don't do that but
like i
so ben was in la last week and on his
way home he flew united and they have
and just like that and he started to
watch it and he came home and like he
had so many thoughts he's like so what
episode like when does samantha come
back he said i'm not gonna finish it
just like tell me i'm like
i don't know how to tell you this but
she's like not on the show
heartbroken he was like what
he like he obviously doesn't keep up
with pop culture and know that like the
kim catrell sarah jessica parker drama
is like a thing so he was absolutely
devastated he said it was the worst show
he's ever seen in his life like cringy
so try hard spoiler alert
he couldn't get over that they killed
big like
he imagine like not caring so like
caring so little about pop culture that
not knowing a year later that big does
yeah like could never be me no never
no it's crazy that they like brought
back the show just to kill big yeah and
samantha like yeah the two
more likeable characters and i have to
say i remember recapping it like i did
actually really enjoy the show but it
was like a hate watching thing and i
don't think like if i had to you know
give a critical analysis of the show
what i say it was very good but um i did
enjoy it
well i mean they would
they should bring samantha back and they
still won't and they'll just tease [ __ ]
like this and that's annoying for the
fans but i don't think samantha's return
is their choice i think it's samantha's
choice i think now it's both you know
because she's also like trash them and
it's really sarah jessica parker's show
and i don't know if she would have her
back
yeah i'm just glad to be like extra
creative from the situation because i
don't watch and so i have no horse in
this race yeah no me neither
and honestly i don't even know if i
would want kim control back because it
would be so awkward between them i don't
think that they could recapture the
magic that the four of them had back in
the day but it was awkward back in the
day too when you listened to stories yes
but it wasn't as bad as it is of course
of course and i think everyone would
just be watching being like these people
hate each other yeah and it's hard to
watch movies with people who hate each
other kissing booth too
jacob lordy and joey king yeah literally
i think half of their scenes were filmed
in like a split screen because they
refused to be in the same room
talk about no chemistry no you can't
date if you're gonna ruin the franchise
a hundred percent like either do it in
your contract it should be like are you
mature enough to if you fall in love
with this person be able to work with
them again no the contract should be
like are you planning on dating your
co-star yes okay i will only fork over
the salary if you plan to date them up
until this franchise is over are you
open to dating your co-star yes
are you open to if you break up still
being an adult and being able to work
with them yeah yes i have to say like
not that i know anything about the
situation but from the kissing booth too
i do feel like it was jacob lordy who
like couldn't stand joey king i don't
know if he was hurt but i think the vibe
that i got which is based on absolutely
nothing is that he was the one who like
made it awkward okay so he'll need to
have that in his contract going forward
yeah and he loves to date co-stars he
was spotted with zendaya like it's not
for everyone it's not for everyone
are you ready for our next story
only if it's a story that's brought to
you
by stamps.com it is when you're running
a small business every second counts you
can't afford to waste a single moment so
why are you still taking time out of
your day going to the post office when
you could be using stamps.com instead
stamps.com makes mailing and shipping
quick easy and cost effective for more
than 20 years they have been an
indispensable resource for over 1
million businesses they give you access
to the post office and ups shipping
services right from your computer you
can get discounts you can't find
anywhere like up to 30 percent off usps
rates and 86 percent off ups streamline
your shipping process with stamps.coms
easy to use software all you need is
your computer and a printer there's no
extra supplies or equipment required and
you're up and running in minutes
printing any official us postage for any
letter any package anywhere you want to
send they work seamlessly with shopify
amazon etsy ebay and more stop wasting
time and start saving money when you use
stamps.com to mail and ship sign up with
promo code toast for special offers that
include a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale there's no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
page and enter code toast
great our next story the internet is
losing its mind over a couple who said
they had minnie and mickey at their
wedding instead of food
reddit users went off on a person who
claimed in a forum that she and her
husband skipped catering their wedding
so they can afford an appearance by
mickey and minnie mouse my fiance and i
just got married two months ago and we
had our dream wedding the ready for you
wrote however she wrote she's a
self-described huge disney fan quote
about a month and a half ago my aunt
started posting on facebook about how
disappointed she was with the whole
ordeal and a few guests sided with her
the cost to have both minnie and mickey
for a good chunk of time 30 minutes was
almost exactly what our parents allotted
for our catering budget so we scheduled
an appearance during our first dance and
our wedding photos for going served food
though there were plenty of facilities
at the venue where people could eat
and then the post was removed by their
honor
yeah buy their own food the moderator
said that they remove posts from feeds
for a variety of reasons including
keeping communities safe civil and true
to their purpose but the screenshot of
that girl's like testimony has made its
way around the internet because you can
delete everything you want but the
internet lives forever and remembers
everything minnie began trending on
twitter
okay so my thoughts on this are twofold
obviously
my first is that um
foregoing food to like
sorry foregoing food
to mickey and minnie at your wedding is
so
[Music]
unwell like
it's delusional
but
it's your wedding and you can really do
whatever you want so like
don't invite me but like sure i empower
other couples to make their wedding
exactly how they want to be but you are
an unwell human being
but
your aunt going on facebook and like
starting a thread a month later about
your wedding like oh my god okay you
just missed one meal calm the [ __ ] down
it's definitely weird and definitely
worth gossiping about behind the bride's
back 100 but to start a thread on
facebook like that's kind of next level
diabolical yeah i agree but if ann had
started this we would never know so i'm
grateful to the auntie but i'm just
gonna play devil's advocate for a second
you know because
we all eat three meals a day
happens every day most of the time some
people more some people less and to miss
one meal so that these people could have
their dream whatever it is you know
everyone dreams differently like it's
their wedding it just meant like you
didn't have lunch but they got mickey
and minnie in their pictures forever
okay small praise stupid i have two
things to say small praise to pay i have
two things to say
one if these people were on four
weddings they literally would have come
in last place you ever watched four
weddings no i've never even heard of it
what oh man me and olivia used to be
obsessed with the show can i tell you
what it's about it's a tlc show four
brides are competing they all go to
their they all plan their weddings and
it's not sponsored at all like they all
plan it on their own budget
and each of the four brides
goes to each other's weddings and grades
it based on experience
food overall fun the dress
and then at the end of the
show all the couples are waiting
together at like this bachelor style
mansion and whoever gets the highest
score gets a free honeymoon cute it's a
really good show but the brides are
[ __ ] evil like literally if they have
to wait one extra second for their food
or like if their food comes out like
lukewarm but not warm enough three three
out of ten for food it shouldn't be the
fellow brides judging each other because
of course they're gonna want to sabotage
so they can win it should be like
professional partygoers say you and i
who are do who are the professional
judges yeah they don't have a horse in
the race their scoring system does
try and negate people giving
intentionally low scores like i think
i don't forget how they do it but they
have a system it's not perfect for sure
but it's such a good show and like
people
the other brides find the most insane
things to complain about at other
people's weddings just to justify giving
a lower score and if this couple was on
four weddings like i could just imagine
the episode so that was the first thing
that came to mind
second of all i do hear what you're
saying like yes to forego a meal however
and there were vendors around however
there are people traveling for your
wedding do you live in orlando you know
what i mean is this a destination
wedding i don't think so no i don't
think so it sounds like it was like an
afternoon wedding okay like a luncheon i
just feel like if you're not gonna serve
food like you do have to let people know
for sure
you do have to let people know so they
could bring a snack or they could bring
you know some money for the vending
machine no i would then literally bring
in like a fiber one bar in my clutch or
have a big meal before or after
yeah no i guess like the the concept
that people are like hanging on to is
like instead of giving you know the
people you love in your life like an
experience to remember you had mickey
and minnie and you're grown adults like
that's what i think of course would i
choose it for myself no i value food
more than i value mickey and minnie
but
say it wasn't say it was like kim
of course i would i would forgo
i would forego food for kim a hundred
percent and that's the same thing like
don't yuck their yums say some people
wanted to hire the streisbrothers to
come to their wedding bryce and strikes
they'll be in all of your pictures but
bryce and stress would do it for free
that's the difference okay but say like
their fee even just to fly them out to
your wedding was the same as the food so
they foregoed food to have the stress
brothers at your wedding and yeah
pictures
what are you gonna do i guess it's just
the way that she wrote the post like how
obvious like of course we let go of the
food right and it's an in a forum where
you post to find out if you're in the
wrong or to tell someone else they're in
the wrong or to sit back and just watch
that is a great concept for a forum
right so that's why everybody is
weighing in because that's the point of
the she asked right that's interesting
so i agree like it could never be me and
if that's gonna be you like sure but
like i do think you're like
ill like not okay
of course and at the end of the day if i
were a guest at this wedding i would
never stop making fun of them i probably
would never talk to you yet yeah no i
would be hungry i'd be hangry
but i just i always like to offer an
alternate person no and you're like you
are right like at the end of the day
it's your wedding like your wedding is
your choice however you choose to spend
your money like a hundred percent it's
just probably the weirdest thing i've
ever heard in my life it's a weird
choice for sure
could never be me but like i empower you
to make your own choices you're on weird
choices yeah that's freedom yeah you
know freedom
freedom
freedom you got it no we were going back
and forth on freedom
speaking of singing are you ready for
our fifth and final story yeah
oh [ __ ] you didn't look ready
how does this gonna go
wherever the chips may fall we're even
now okay so you'll never know what i'm
gonna do wow you're such a loose cannon
it's the final story
i want my dinner now
[Laughter]
no
scary
scariest wedding guest
oh my
scariest wedding guest totally of all
time she wants her dinner no
that's like how they used to sing in
temple
that is how they sung
if you and ben weren't like an
influencer duo you would be a rabbi and
a cantor duo yeah or just two cantors do
wedding actually but you guys would like
me
this town's only big enough for one
counter each of you would want the last
note by the way for those who don't know
what a cantor is like when you go to
temple there's a rabbi and a cantor in
the cantor it's like a really beautiful
voice and sings all the prayers and for
a brief period in my life like i really
thought i could be the next big canner
and ben really has it in him you guys
heard how he did the final story like
that's the exact tenor of a of a camper
i'm sorry i'm a canter
i keep
in my head i was like i'm gonna have to
say camber i'm like no camper i want my
dinner now
[Music]
amen our fifth and final story a little
tech news
io 16 will let you edit and even
unsensitive text
messages what did you call it ios
it's ios right
yeah i see ios
that's like the chapstick
it's eos
it's ios like say it how you want but i
just want to like let you know it's ios
you don't think there's people who call
it ios i just found out there is you
there's people like me we can start a
community
anyways during its wwdc 2022 event apple
announced a bunch of new features on the
way for its software platforms including
the ability to edit messages you've
already sent in its messages app apple
software engineering vp announced the
changes while discussing ios 16 updates
adding that users will be able to unsend
messages and mark threads unread to
easily revisit them later covering three
of the most requested features from
imessage users
unsend messages
edit messages and mark threads unread to
easily this is what has
this is what i need because usually i
said what i said and i meant it but i
need the ability if i open a message to
leave it unread just like i do with my
emails to know that i need to come back
to it 100 i completely forget about text
messages all the time because i open
them forget about them and move on to be
honest like the fact that apple has to
have like a whole presentation to add
like the unread feature is so stupid
like put it in an update like you don't
need to make like a whole conference
about it it's so simple yeah they do
their conference for like other things
and you know showing us the new ipad or
this or that yeah um and now it's really
like their biggest pr thing and people
could be get used to and like people sit
around like waiting for it to go live no
people like literally stand outside and
live stream themselves which is an
interesting way to spend your day but
like other people have mickey and minnie
at their wedding right right everybody's
different
um
they also said that the edit or recall
for a message will be up to 15 minutes
after sending it but what if the person
has already seen it yeah no and then you
could gaslight that meaning i didn't say
that i think it'll be just like
um
first of all i think it will say edited
if it's been edited and you probably
also get a message when someone
something was unsent like you do on
instagram that's my favorite like when i
get a whole flood of
in my on my homepage someone unsent a
message on sentiments i'm like oh
someone's defecting and they're ashamed
that they were once crawled up see like
i feel i feel like with the onsen you
should only be able to unsend a message
that the person hasn't opened yet
yeah of course and apple should be able
to tell you that like if unsend comes up
as an option that means they haven't
seen it yet and if it doesn't come up as
an option the person hasn't seen it yet
to unsend a message that someone already
saw is like literally not the point
yeah i guess like just the [ __ ] like say
you like drunk texting and then the next
morning you could like erase all of them
and assuming the person didn't take a
screenshot yeah they know that you did
it but like you could wipe the slate but
they already got it so the message is
done you know yeah
i do like that thing the option for an
edit button because like as someone who
literally cannot write one sentence
without typos it's true just to be able
to instead of doing asterisk and then
say the typo again and then asterisk
again the asterisk is going to go out of
business i love that i'm a frequent
asterisk user and you don't even bother
you write blah blah blah
two weeks later it's like why didn't you
do that i'm like what did you tell me to
do blah blah i don't bother with you but
like when i'm talking to like other
people who like don't know how i
communicate i have to use my asterisk
but you don't and that's why like sophia
with an f thought what what 1 30 and 10
30 1 30 and 10 30 exactly totally
but now you could edit that but it also
would require you to register error yeah
so i will definitely be using edit i
would like more clarification on what
the unsend rules are
yeah it might just be like for your own
peace of mind
yeah like the way instagram does it is
pretty good
yeah you can unsend it but you also see
that they saw it so i will never unsend
something somebody already saw people
don't have not everyone has their read
receipts on on instagram they do no on
twitter yeah i know so i'm curious how
it's gonna work and i don't want you to
know when i'm reading stuff no i got a
new phone and like for the first month
nobody bothered to tell me my reader
seats were on
no it wasn't that it was like this do
not disturb this was like a while ago oh
and i just remember like literally shout
out matt hardoon ben's friend was like
why are your read receipts on i'm like
what nobody had told me like not even
ben oh i have mad respect for people
with their read receipts on because that
means that they get around to things
like i couldn't have my receipts on
because you would see that i read it the
moment that you sent it and i never
answered no and it's so embarrassing the
rate in which i
yeah it's embarrassing for me yeah but
now with this new mark is unread like
that's going to be game changing for me
game changing that's what i've needed so
thank you yeah no this sounds good yeah
give people what they want yeah we'll
see how it goes i'm happy for the drunk
texters yeah
that's going to be good huge
huge for the drug testing industry
um we dive into your toasters our advice
segment let's and if any of you were
drunk texting any device there's your
advice and it's brought to you by modern
fertility knowledge is power and when
you know more you can make better
decisions for your body your health and
your future and there aren't many
decisions bigger than having a kid but
for many women for their fertility is a
big question mark and that's why modern
fertility was created it's an easy and
affordable way to test your fertility
hormones at home with a simple
fingerprint prick mail it in the mail
with a prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within 10 days
insights into your hormone levels your
ovarian reserve other important
fertility factors the results go deep
into what every hormone means and you
can also talk one on one with fertility
nurse to review your results and options
for next steps traditional testing with
your doctor can cost over a thousand
dollars but modern fertility gets you
the same information at 159
which is a fraction of the price and if
you go to modernfertility.com
toast you'll get 20 off that test
leaving it at just 139
if you have hsa or fsa you can put those
dollars towards modern fertility so if
you want kids today or maybe one day in
the future clinically sound information
about your body can help you make that
decision for for you
right now modern fertility is helping
our listeners with twenty dollars off
the test when you go to
modernfertility.com
toast that means your test will cost 139
instead of the hundreds or thousands it
could cost at the doctor's office get 20
off your fertility test when you go to
modern fertility modernfertility.com
toast
modernfertility.com toast knowledge is
power you guys
dear toasters our advice segment we do
every wednesday you can submit your
submissions at deartoasters gmail.com
dear harry theo bruce jackie and claudia
an order of importance
me last wow
i moved away from my city a year ago
with a solid group of friends we worked
together for years we went on girls
trips and we were super close i was
particularly close with one girl named
margot margot got engaged a month before
i moved leading up to it we had talked
so much about the future wedding where
we wanted to go for the bachelorette
party and i was so excited excited to
help her plan her big day
fast forward a few months my old friends
and even some new ones who were
introduced three months before the
engagement were posting on social media
with their will you be my bridesmaid
gift box i assumed mine was in the mail
but nothing ever arrived we facetime
once every few weeks and catch up like
nothing is wrong talk about wedding
stuff and we say that we need to get
together soon the wedding is now two
months away and i haven't been asked to
be a bridesmaid go on the bachelorette
party the bridal shower or anything
except to be a guest i feel super left
out it makes me not even want to go to
the wedding anymore it's a flight across
the country a rental car and a hotel for
a girl who seemingly doesn't really want
me and her life is anything more than
acquaintance but if i don't go it will
be awkward in our group and might sever
the relationship for good what would you
do signed a forgotten toaster
honestly
what damn like
there's nothing worse than like the
feeling that you're not wanted you know
yeah and like sometimes you're like
overreacting but usually if you're
feeling that way like
it's kind of the vibe like if you're not
invited somewhere it's because they
didn't want to invite you of course but
there's
a difference between not being someone's
bridesmaid and like not being wanted
period and i think you're not going to
the wedding would sever a relationship
that like is still pretty good i mean
it's a bummer that she didn't ask you to
be a bridesmaid you never know like what
her reasons were but it doesn't mean
that you should like give up the whole
friendship and like what about the other
girls and like that would just sour
this relationship that you have with
this group of friends and i'm i
understand that it's hurtful
but
i don't think you should throw away like
the whole friendship group of friends
and or even just like cause such a stink
like you'll have a fun weekend at the
wedding not ever like i have so many
friends close friend so i don't just
consider acquaintances who were at my
wedding that weren't bridesmaids or my
bachelorette party but like that doesn't
mean you don't come to my wedding yeah i
guess but i don't know if they're like
even still friendly anymore so they only
talk every couple of weeks because she
moved right so that would also explain
why you weren't on the bachelorette
party but like you should still go see
your friends like
i i
yeah i guess i agree like you should be
happy for for other people and really
don't be happy for other people i'm just
saying you should be happy or whatever
it doesn't have to be all or nothing
yeah i'm not very much either a
bridesmaid girl or you're not a friend
yeah i'm an all or nothing girl like if
someone didn't invite you on your back
on their bachelorette you'd say thank
you so much i appreciate you yes i do
you would not be hurt at all i do happen
to dislike bachelorette parties like
immensely
if someone didn't ask you not to be a
bridesmaid you would say thank you so
much you understand me you get me yeah i
don't want to spend the whole day at the
venue getting ready but that's me that's
not this girl right we're right
so everybody is
different
and also like if you had moved away from
all your friends and you were already
feeling like a little untethered and
then you got a blow like this like i
think that would hurt you yeah yeah yeah
i think it's probably like a pile of
things for this girl yeah but i don't
think you should throw away all the
friendships and i think you should go
and have a good time and
and maybe when it's your bachelorette
this is what you should do you should
rush to get engaged rush rush like find
get on hinge get unhinged find someone
to get engaged to you have a
bachelorette party invite everyone
except that girl
everyone except her and then she'll know
how to feel what it's like and then you
can break off the engagement and move on
with you yeah yeah
best advice you've ever given literally
hands down an eye for an eye sometimes
it's the only way
i love when you get like this but an eye
for an eye the whole world goes blind
yeah
and that works for me
honestly as long as we're all not seeing
yeah right why should it just be me
i completely agree
next up dear claudia and jackie i love
you both so much your episodes are
literally getting me through med school
it would mean so much to me if you read
this on the toast one of my guy friends
asked me to come over and make dinner
just us last weekend cute it has always
been friend vibes between us but i was
kind of trying to keep an open mind
because he's a really nice guy we made
dinner we were watching tv afterwards
and low-key i thought it was kind of
awkward and i couldn't see us becoming
more than friends after a while i went
to the bathroom and i noticed that the
medicine cabinet was left slightly open
sure sure it was after i pried it open
with
after i left it slightly open i noticed
it was left slightly open after i opened
it up it was open
so i decided to snoop but when i came
back out he asked me if i checked out
the medicine cabinet what of course then
i had to go look but i still wish i
didn't because what do i find in the
medicine cabinet a [ __ ] condom one
singular con condom keep in mind we
literally hadn't held hands or kissed or
anything of the sort i was totally
prepared to just pretend i didn't see it
but of course as soon as i came out
again he asked me what i thought about
it i told him
run why are you still typing this run i
told him i didn't want to ruin our
friendship and i left soon afterwards
good the problem is that we're part of
the same close friend group at a small
school and there's no way to avoid
seeing him for the next few years what
should i do should i tell him how
disrespectful and inappropriate that was
or should i just pretend this never
happened lastly should i stay upset or
just chalk this up to a really funny
story sincerely a slightly disturbed
toaster i have to say of all the ways
i've heard of like men trying to get
women into bed this is a new one this is
so did you see that one condom in my
medicine cabinet what did you think
would you think that's horrific if you
didn't have the ick from him before like
you certainly have it now that's the
ickiest thing i've ever heard now what
you should do is obviously avoid him at
all costs and in order to like have your
friends avoid him too just tell them the
story yeah tell everyone the story i
don't know if like i do feel like his
heart was in the right place he's just
like a cringy man no i don't think so
like that's really really bad yeah
there's some like either if you want to
come like
come on to someone
use your words yeah i agree we're all
adults like
that is like really [ __ ] creepy no
it's so weird it's when she did leave it
open they were honestly
yeah no they all right sorry we totally
accused you we totally accused you
especially they were on the couch like
they had just made dinner she was
keeping an open mind like could have
been natural put the moves on yeah but
the high behind your condom in the
medicine cabinet is so
weird that's lazy and it also just means
like he just wants to [ __ ] you like he
doesn't want to be in a relationship
with you
so weird that is cringe master 3000 like
i i'm i'm in pain for you yeah and
honestly like you really should never
speak to this person again he's
obviously unwell obviously no seriously
like i'm not even joking run run
run
like you run from it all
oh that's funny i was thinking run by
lauren elena
so again
daddy said the truck's all yours if you
let it run
do you know this song it's so big no i
don't think so it's so good i'll listen
to it listen to that and then don't
forget to listen to seoul by leigh bryce
and then um the morning chose patreon
also uh so that's our advice run right
run run run for the hills
run forest run
run a slightly disturbed toaster run
our third and final dear toaster
submission
i'm in quite a peculiar pickle my
boyfriend's friend was recently dumped
by his long-term girlfriend and my pgm
boyfriend has been trying to keep him
busy my boyfriend's friend was dumped by
his girlfriend so the p john boyfriend
is trying to keep the friend busy
he makes sure to include him whenever
possible even if it's third willing with
my boyfriend and i i love his friend but
we have an issue he never pays or even
offers to pay for anything when we go
out how should we approach this subject
to him we understand he's going through
it we are not made of money we don't
want to stop including him just because
he won't pay but enough is enough i
sincerely appreciate any words of advice
from two beautiful stunning smart
girlies so many things you can do to get
him to pay but first i would say like
okay his girlfriend broke up with him it
doesn't mean you have to like adopt him
and make sure he has a warm meal i just
want to say he's not terminally ill
he's heartbroken he'll be fine no like
it's really not a big deal like ronnie
you got him on a dating app and like
right he's not an orphan he can find
someone else to pay for him yeah but
a few things you could do one you guys
go to dinner and you leave him with the
check and say you got this one like we
got all the other ones two you guys if
he makes you pay you then venmo him and
if he doesn't ever get the message then
you either then you either say something
or you stop inviting him or you stop
inviting him and you tell him it's
because he doesn't pay like you are not
a charity and this behavior needs to
stop yeah no are you a 501c3 i don't
think so you're not tax exempt and you
don't need to be paying for this
grown-ass man's meals all the time yeah
messed up people have such a nerve no
the self-awareness like the lack of
self-awareness when it comes to money
with people in our generation is
astounding like whether it's been mowing
me 50 cents for like the uh vending
machine pretzels we split or like not
offering to pay like people especially
when people write in like you really see
how people are so weird about money yeah
and it's like so uncomfortable and it
really can like ruin a friendship and
that's where that age-old phrase come
from comes from like you don't mix
business with pleasure of course but let
me just think about it from another
angle for a second like are you guys is
he glomming on to your plans or like are
you insisting he come with you because
you're worried about him because if like
you're always the ones doing in the
inviting and then what if he's not
someone who would be dining out all this
time he's like why should i times a week
why should i pay when like you guys
asked me to come and like i wouldn't be
going out to dinner i don't spend my
money like that that's interesting too
we need to understand who invited you
and at the end of the day like you guys
need to break free like you're not a
throttle this just sounds like a toxic
he's fine he'll be fine he's fine next
time you see him just like download an
app for him so that he can
find someone or like if you want to
spend time with him and make sure he's
okay like stan
right
right stan
cook order pizza like low budget low
budget you know yeah it doesn't have to
be like a
all the cameras coming out for republic
affair when you take this guy out you
know 100 there's no there's no need for
extravagance save that for date night
honestly yeah
no or start oh and say by the way say
he's being a hazard like that's just
what it is and he's insisting because
he's so sad and heartbroken start going
to like really gross restaurants yeah
take them to the motel six yeah no like
go to restaurants with like a d
cockroach
yeah put a little cool yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah put a mice in your a mouse in
your purse yeah
i love that for you yeah or like
whatever his least favorite cuisine is
like keep going it sounds like you guys
are spoiling him like
yeah and you're wondering why he needs
to be knocked down a few pegs because
honestly sounds like you made him a
monster yeah which could happen and like
that's why they say no good deed goes
unpunished so true no good deed goes on
punish and that's why if you do no good
deeds you'll never be punished gorgeous
that's today's lesson and that's today's
show that is today's show on a wednesday
which as discussed is sometimes good
sometimes bad as aforementioned
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you are watching this on youtube
please subscribe
please subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up yes but you know i think you
need to redirect your efforts because
like we have way more subscribers than
we have viewers which means the viewers
have subscribed but so what you need to
ask is for the podcast listeners just go
and subscribe even though it means
nothing to them just for your ego
what jackie said podcast listeners just
go onto youtube and subscribe to us we
won't bother you yeah we will not bother
you there we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
set spotify itunes stitcher public radio
i have radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning
and smart we are hope you guys have an
incredible wednesday and we'll see you
tomorrow once we're over the hump on
thursday can't wait goodbye
you